Ahora otra cosa que para un judio este libro demuestra claramente es
Que Cristo es nuestro Sumo Sacerdote,
Una cosa, un cambio radical para un Judio,
El Sumo Sacerdote era el ser humano más respetado sobre el planeta,
Talvez el Sumo Sacerdote fue mas respetado que el papa de hoy,
Porque el cada año hacia una expiacion y la expiacion de sus almas dependia de el,
O sea ante Dios el si tenía una posición de mucha honra como hebreos 4 dice.
Ahora en cursos pasados de Hebreos hemos visto escrituras aquí en Hebreos
Que hablan del Sumo Sacerdocio de Cristo, pero yo si creo que debemos darle honra a quien si merece honra
Y el hermano Juan Carlos un buen estudioso de la escritura,
Hace ratos me mostro que la revelacion principal del Sumo Sacerdote en Hebreos
Es precisamente su ministerio en el dia de expiacion o sea Yom Kippur,
No hay duda es cierto, es cierto y vamos a tomarlo en cuenta durante el curso de vez en cuando
Es un punto muy importante, pero eso era un buen chispazo en mi corazon,(gracias al hermano)
Y empece a ver que hay una razon muy trascendental
Porque Cristo es presentado aqui como el Sumo Sacerdote en el dia de expiacion
Y lo veremos, entonces  ya es la introduccion  breve.